All right.
Audience questions.
I, I'm finding that I'm getting better at
picking yes.
Some
of these lately I'm having a better sense
of what is the audience actually interested
in.
We had a lot of duds early on.
Okay.
The question, uh, my fault, of course.
Not anybody else's, um, poor selection.
The first question today, could Trump voters
be convinced to vote for someone like Bernie
or Warren?
If Bernie or Warren, when were the nominees?
There's always like two if not three answers
to these.
Is it possible question?
The first is, of course it's possible some
Democrats voted for Trump.
So in a sort of general abstract sense, yes,
there are Trump voters who would be, uh, convincible
to vote for Bernie or Warren.
Uh, and many of them would just do it without
needing to be convinced merely because they're
not pleased with Donald Trump's some fraction
of them.
Now, what is the real philosophy that would
be the most cleanly, uh, a transitional one
from being a Trump voter in 2016 to a Bernie
or Warren voter in 2020?
I think that it is populism now.
It's really important.
I have no confusion that the populistic rhetoric
of Donald Trump is number one bogus.
But number two, it's a right wing rhetoric
is a more nationalist rhetoric, a nationalist,
populist rhetoric.
It is not at all the same thing as the left
progressive rhetoric, certainly of Bernie
Sanders and to some degree of Elizabeth Warren.
But the messaging, at least at the superficial
level, can seem quite similar between Trump's
pho, right populism and Bernie and Warren's
actual left populism.
So there is no doubt that if you were attracted
to Trump in 2016 on the basis of his populistic
ish, I mean it's such a, I'm hedging, it's
not populist, it's populistic ish sort of
rhetoric.
Um, then there is actually a sort of credible
path to get over to somebody like Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren.
And in fact, anecdotally we heard about, uh,
Bernie primary supporters who ended up voting
for Trump, which I was a Bernie primary supporting
supporter in 60, and I think it would have
been absolutely whacked to support Trump.
Uh, and here we are, Trump having to supreme
court picks and almost going to war with like
three countries, which Hillary simply would
not have done.
Not that I was a Hillary lover by any means.
The problem with like a big picture move from
Trump voters to Bernie or Warren on policy
and philosophy rather than merely on they're
displeased with Trump and maybe they'll vote
for the alternative is that there is no real
coalition within the American.
Right.
That fits into the Bernie Warren thing.
There, the right populous rhetoric of 2016
may work to get some people just but, but
by sort of a numbers game to support Bernie
or Warren.
But we, you know, it's not like the Evangelical,
right that ultimately went for Trump, even
though early they liked Cruz and whoever else,
that's not a coalition that's going to get
behind Bernie or war.
And even though I would make the argument
that Bernie and Warren's policy is much more
in line with what evangelical Christianity
at least claims to stand for, if not actually
stands for, um, the, you know, the pro gun
coalition that ultimately got behind Trump
because he said some stuff about liking guns
or whatever, they're not going to get behind
Bernie or Warren.
So I think that's the issue.
And then the most important thing to point
out is I don't think it's a good strategy
to try to win 2020 by convincing Trump voters
from 2016 to vote for Bernie or Warren or
whoever the Democratic nominee is.
We saw earlier this this week that Emma vigilant
clip from earlier this week where Emma, I
interviewed just maybe the dumbest Trump supporter
we've ever seen who said she wouldn't vote
for Joe Biden because of something related
to white slash black, uh, of referring to
race and Biden's a socialist because he's
all about the money and he's a billionaire.
None of that's true, but this is what the
woman said.
It was made abundantly clear.
That would have been saying for a year or
more at this point is right as a strategy
for winning elections.
Don't try to convince Trump as to vote for
someone else.
Just get the half of the people on the left
who didn't vote last time to vote.
You don't have to convince them of anything
other than just to go out and vote.
That's much easier than completely upending
the, the beliefs as harebrained and fact free
as they may be of a lot of these Trumpists.